foreign
cyber security Engineers Shield systems
and it works from cyber threats by
implementing security measures like
farewells and encryption they identify
vulnerabilities through security
assessments and respond to incident by
investigating and mitigating damage
cyber security Engineers contribute to
the design of secure architectures
monitor for threats and promote security
awareness they ensure complaints with
regulations and stay updated on emerging
threats to adapt security measures
accordingly Now list the agenda for
today's session to begin we will explore
the responsibilities and roles of cyber
security Engineers next we will dive
into the essential skills required for
cyber security Engineers after that we
will examine the U.S cyber security
Engineers salary for entry level and
experienced professionals following the
salary discussion we will discuss the
various career opportunities in cyber
security lastly we will the leading
companies that offer High salaries to
cyber security engineers in the U.S if
you are ready to unlock your full
potential in cyber security look no
further than the postgraduate program in
cyber security it is specifically
designed to provide you with the
necessary skills to become an expert in
the fast growing field of cyber security
this comprehensive program ensures that
you are up to date with the latest
trends in the ever evolving field of
cyber security isolate your career in
the field of cyber security with a
comprehensive curriculum that includes
certification aligned courses this
certification program in cyber security
starts by covering introductory level
skills and gradually advances to explore
cutting its cyber security Technologies
check out the course Link in the
description for more details now let's
explore the essential skills that equips
cyber security Engineers with expertise
to safeguard organizations from cyber
threats and uphold a secure digital
environment and first we have technical
proficiency cyber security Engineers
need to have strong technical skills and
knowledge in areas such as network
security operate systems programming
languages and security tools these
expertise allows them to analyze and
protect complex systems and networks
effectively and next we have problem
solving and analytical thinking cyber
security Engineers must possess
excellent problem solving skills to
identify vulnerabilities analyst
security incidents and develop effective
solutions they should be able to think
critically and apply logical reasoning
to address complex cyber security
challenges and next knowledge of cyber
security principles and Concepts a deep
understanding of cyber security
principles Concepts and Frameworks is
essential this include familiarity with
security standards secure coding
practices thread modeling risk
assessment methodologies and secure
network architecture
and then we have continuous learning and
adaptability the cyber security
landscape constantly evolves with new
threats and Technologies emerging cyber
security Engineers must rest for
continuous learning staying updated on
the latest trends attending training
programs and adapting their skills and
strategies to address evolving cyber
security challenges and then we have
ethical and legal understanding cyber
security Engineers must possess a strong
ethical foundation and an understanding
of legal considerations in the field of
cyber security they should adhere to
ethical guidelines respect privacy
regulations and have knowledge of laws
related to cyber security data
protection and incident reporting now
it's time to dive into the exciting
world of cyber security Engineers
salaries in the United States spanning
both entry level and experienced
Professionals for those starting their
Journey job designations and their
respective annual salaries are as
follows so first we have cyber security
analyst average annual salary in the
United States is 96 000 and as you
progress in your career the earning
potential reaches New Heights with
salary for experienced professionals a
cyber security manager salary in the
United States is 168
000 per year whereas the security
operations center analyst salary is 66
000 and
the security engineer salary is 131 000
per year and then Junior penetration
tester salary is ninety three thousand
dollars per year and cheap information
security officer salary is 289
000 per year so whether you're just
beginning or have ample experience cyber
Security offers promising opportunities
to thrive and grow let's now shift our
Focus to the various career
opportunities available in cyber
security as a demand for cyber Security
Professionals grows diverse rules and
specializations emerge offering numerous
career advancements and specializations
path some of the wide range of career
opportunities available in cyber
security include cyber security analysts
ethical hacker or penetration tester
cyber security engineer cryptographer
forensic analyst and security architect
now let's take a closer look at the
companies that offer higher salaries to
cyber security engineers in the United
States and first in our list we have
Google with an average salary of 152 000
per year Google provides competitive
compensations to attract top cyber
security talent and next we have
Microsoft Microsoft offers a salary
range of 150 000 to 278 000 annually
providing a lucrative earning potential
for cyber security engineers
and next we have Amazon
offering a salary range of 191 thousand
dollars to three hundred and nineteen
thousand dollars annually Amazon is
known for providing High competitive
salaries to cyber Security Professionals
next Cisco Systems Cisco Systems provide
a salary to approximately 169
000 annually to cyber security Engineers
ensuring a rewarding compensation
package and next we have IBM
with an average salary of 933 000 IBM
offers a competitive composition package
to cyber security engineers next
Raytheon Technologies radio technology
offers a salary range of 100 000 to 151
000 annually providing attractive
earning opportunities for cyber Security
Professionals next Bose Allen Hamilton
so this offers a salary range of 95 000
to 142 000 annually providing
competitive compositions for cyber
security engineers
and finally we have fire eye fire eye
offers a salary range of 167 000 to 260
000 annually providing High earning
potential for cyber Security
Professionals it's important to note
that these salary figures can vary based
on location experience certification and
specific job responsibility within each
company now let's take a minute to hear
from our Learners who have experienced
new success in their careers hi I'm
Philip I'm 61 years old and last year I
upscure was simple as postgraduate
program in cyber security after working
30 years in the IIT sector in various
different profiles I'm happy to tell you
that I was able to clear and pass my
cissp and ccsp certification exams on
the first attempt after taking the
course course I must say was packed with
practical examples it was led by highly
skilled certified instructors I worked
with many companies before the security
analysts and the architect on a contract
basis but I needed some ability which I
got with the job I just started with
Infosys as a cyber security consultant
happened after I took the course but
first and foremost I've been a learner
be a learner first
with this we have come to the end of
this video on cyber security salary in
the U.S if you like this video subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the Bell
icon to never miss any updates from
Simply learn until next time thank you
and keep learning